Hallo, hallo, hallo.
Jebaited, korrekt.
Massive Jebait.
Mein Fahrrad ist immer noch nicht da.
DHL schreibt jetzt seit 3 Tagen,
dass es im, Moment, Moment, wie heißt das?
Ich muss mal kurz nachgucken.
Im Zielverteilzentrum oder sowas.
Moment, lass mich mal kurz schauen.
DHL sagt,
die Sendung ist in der Region des Empfängers angekommen
und wird im nächsten Schritt zur Zustellbasis transportiert.
Das sagen die jetzt schon seit 3 Tagen.
Ich bestelle ein Fahrrad.
Vor dem Winter, warum nicht?
Das Beste ist,
das ist eigentlich so wie bei vielem,
wenn man Bock hat, mit irgendwas anzufangen,
macht es gleich
und schiebt das nicht irgendwie auf,
weil man glaubt gar nicht,
wie gut die Sache schon immer ein halbes Jahr später läuft,
wenn das was für einen ist.
Vielleicht stellt man auch fest,
das ist nichts für einen Doktor Pronup.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ja, also keine Ahnung,
was mir DHL damit sagen will,
dass es dreimal jetzt schon in der Region des Empfängers angekommen ist.
Ich dachte eigentlich,
dass das Paket nur einmal in der Region des Empfängers ankommen könnte.
Es ist dann einfach die ganze Zeit noch in der Region des Empfängers da.
Naja, gut.
Man weiß nicht, was DHL da treibt.
Das ist nicht mal aktuell.
Da gibt es neuere Streams,
muss man im Archiv gucken,
wo ich richtig echtes Arch-Linux,
by the way, installiere
und nicht so Fake-Arch-Linux,
wie Manjaro.
Fake-Arch ist nicht mal angesagt.
Echtes Arch, by the way.
Nur dann kann man sich echt
echter Arch-Linux-User...
Du meinst, der fährt mein Fahrrad zu mir heim?
Ja, das könnte natürlich sein.
Das würde es erklären, dass es ein bisschen dauert.
Wobei, so weit weg ist es gar nicht.
Ich mache mal kurz ein Package-Update.
Moin, Tomux.
Guck, der Pepo ist auch schon kurz
vor Bett getimed.
Ja, Igel, mach mal Ausrufezeichen.
Ich glaube, Archiv oder so.
Dann findest du die Seite,
wo es das Archiv gibt.
Du kannst sogar...
Moment, was?
Exa mit Eza?
What?
Moment.
Haben die sich umbenannt?
Siehste, wo wir da dabei sind.
Ein weiterer Grund,
warum ich von diesem ganzen
Wir-rewriten-jeden-Scheiß-in-Rust-Nix
halte.
Ich benutze es eigentlich gar nicht.
Ich kann es jetzt gerade mal kurz removen.
Da hast du dann irgend so ein unmaintainedes Ding.
Da bleibe ich lieber beim Standard-LS.
Und mache ich ja auch.
Ich verwende das eigentlich gar nicht mehr.
Wow, Alter, was ist denn hier los?
Was will der hier alles updaten?
Haha.
Bester Name.
Hört sich an, als muss mal kurz einer eine Runde
Pepo-Pupu machen.
Abseil C++.
Moment, Moment.
Ist das ein Joke darauf,
dass C++ so kacke ist?
Was ist Abseil C++?
Okay, das haben wir uns schon mal angeguckt.
Kommen Abseilen...
Okay, was auch immer es ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, dann lassen wir den noch mal updaten.
Leute, 4,4 Gig
Updates, gib ihm.
Da wird jetzt Windows erstmal
20 Minuten für brauchen.
Aber Arch, by the way, ist da natürlich
schneller.
Man sollte Fairness halber sagen, Pac-Man ist da schneller.
Und danach müssen wir noch die ganzen
User-Repos updaten.
Wie war eigentlich das
Meeting, wo du extra hingefahren bist?
Was war das?
Ach das, du meinst letzte Woche.
Letzte Woche Freitag.
Ja, du meinst das Top-Secret-Meeting,
wo ich nichts zu erzählen darf.
Ja, das hat alles funktioniert.
Aber Top-Secret.
Chat.
Ihr dürft nichts erzählen, ne?
Noch nicht mal, dass es das gegeben hat.
Aber ich weiß ja,
sowas ist sicher bei euch.
Öffentlich im Internet ist das eigentlich immer das Beste,
sowas zu sagen.
Deswegen kann ich euch da auch nichts Großartiges drüber erzählen.
Aber es war nichts super Spannendes.
Ich hab da ein paar Sachen
getippt.
Eine Sache kann ich euch erzählen,
das ist nicht geheim Top-Secret.
Das werde ich wahrscheinlich
auch nicht mehr erleben.
Dass es nochmal passiert.
Und zwar, guck mal hier, Update fertig.
4,4 Gig.
Ich musste bei diesem
Top-Secret-Geheim-Meeting ein paar Sachen
eintippen.
Und das eine war ein bisschen längere
kryptische Zeichenfolge.
Und ich hab irgendwie gefühlt,
was weiß ich wie viel das waren,
160 Zeichen oder so, ohne zu sehen,
was ich tippe,
fehlerfrei eingetippt.
Und danach haben die Leute applaudiert.
Ich hab tatsächlich
für 160 Zeichen-Tippen
Applaus bekommen.
Das müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen.
Das war jetzt einmal erlebt,
nie wieder wird das passieren.
Gangwayt.
Hat das was?
Ja, ja, ja.
Nein, nein, nichts mit Twitch.
Du musst das Protokoll schreiben.
Nee, zum Glück nicht.
Je nach Meeting
find ich das gar nicht so schlimm.
Als Azubi hab ich immer freiwillig Protokoll geschrieben.
Ich weiß auch nicht mehr, was mich da geritten hat.
Warum? Achso.
Kann sagen, warum geht's ja weiter.
Als Azubi hab ich immer gerne freiwillig Protokoll geschrieben.
Ich glaube,
das war eine meiner
üblichen Taktiken,
um
unangenehmen Sachen
aus dem Weg zu gehen.
Vermutlich.
Ich kann den Zusammenhang nicht mehr herstellen.
Aber ihr kennt das ja wahrscheinlich.
Wenn ihr wisst, dass random
unangenehme Sachen passieren,
dann ist es besser,
man meldet sich freiwillig
zu den unangenehmen Sachen.
Dann werden sie nicht so unangenehm
und man hat dann auch Ruhe.
Ich vermute mal, dass es sowas gewesen ist.
Aber ich weiß nicht mehr,
warum ich als Azubi so oft
freiwillig Protokoll geschrieben hab.
An sich find ich Protokollschreiben kacke.
So dumm vor allem.
Kennt ihr das, wenn dann irgendwelche Leute
in irgendeiner Besprechung sitzen
und sagen dann so,
ja, auf dem ABC-System
ist XYZ kaputt.
Und dann hat dann der
sowieso gesagt,
dass B auf dem A
muss zu Z.
Und ihr denkt euch dann so, Alter, was labert
ihr da eigentlich? Was soll ich denn jetzt aufschreiben?
Am Anfang hab ich
immer gedacht, gerade wo ich noch Azubi war,
das muss man jetzt irgendwie verstehen.
Aber mittlerweile hab ich kapiert,
dass man das eigentlich gar nicht verstehen kann.
Deswegen ist das einfachste, wenn man ein Protokoll schreibt,
einfach danach zu fragen,
okay, schön, dass ihr jetzt Bescheid wisst,
aber was schreibe ich denn ins Protokoll dafür?
Und oftmals kommt dann als Antwort,
ach, lass raus, ist nicht so relevant.
Das ist immer das Geilste.
Wenn dann teilweise 20 Minuten
über irgendwas wild diskutiert wird,
und du fragst dann, ja, was schreiben wir
da ins Protokoll? Ach ne,
lass mal, kein Protokoll.
Leute,
irgendwas stimmt mit der LinuxVM nicht.
Die ist langsamer als sonst.
Was ist denn das?
Ich spür das. Ich spür das.
Irgendwas? Kernel-Update oder so?
Hat's zerstört?
Irgendwas ist da richtig langsam gerade.
Was ist denn da los?
Lass mal was checken.
Ha! Ha! Ha!
Habt ihr's gesehen?
Habt ihr's stoppen gesehen?
Ja, ja, guck mal.
Das hat alle,
guck mal, so alle 10 Sekunden
hat's den Hänger.
Ja, guck mal, guck mal.
Es ist die Frage, ob das
Tastatur-Input ist.
Oh, und was ist jetzt los?
Guck mal, meine Statusbar
ist auch kaputt.
Da hab ich natürlich richtig Bock drauf jetzt.
Erstmal muss ich meine Statusbar...
Alter, ist das...
What the...
Das ist ja hyperlaggy gerade.
Ich glaube,
ich muss mal Kernel downgraden.
Da ist irgendwas kaputt.
Äh, warum...
Das ist bestimmt mein Shell-Plugin,
was nicht richtig funktioniert.
Ja, nice, da sind wir wieder.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir erstmal Kernel downgrade machen.
Alter, ist das laggy.
What the fuck?
Ne, hab ich bestimmt nicht.
Downgrade, ne.
Wie downgrade denn überhaupt
ein Kernel unter Arch Linux?
Hab ich noch nie gemacht.
Ne, wir installieren einfach den LTS-Kernel
und dann ist gut.
LTS, bam.
Zack.
Einfach, wir installieren den LTS-Kernel,
der wird wahrscheinlich wieder besser funktionieren.
Ich glaube, das hat bei Linux wirklich niemand
bisher behauptet.
Ich hab doch rebooted gerade.
Die Guest-Tools,
die sind auf jeden Fall aktiv,
sonst hätte ich nicht Fullscreen-Video.
So, wir rebooten einfach mal schnell
den LTS-Kernel und dann sollte
es besser funktionieren.
Alter, ist das lahm.
Das ist ultra laggy.
Oh ne, Leute, ich hab Systemdeboot.
Wie heißt das? SystemdebootD?
Wie stellt man da überhaupt
die...
Okay, Leute, Premiere. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Wir sollten mal einen Snapshot...
Guck mal, wie lange das hängt.
Wir sollten an der Stelle mal einen Snapshot machen.
Ich bin mir da nicht so ganz sicher.
Oh, ich hab noch einen Snapshot vom 22.8.
Ja, den kann ich löschen.
Den Snapshot vom 22.8.
Ist unsinnig.
Okay, wie macht man in...
Das muss man jetzt mal kurz gucken.
Wie macht man in SystemdebootD?
Wie stellt man da
einen LTS-Kernel ein?
Moin, veganer NicoTM.
Leute, ich werd noch
zum richtigen Weep langsam.
Ich hab jetzt
die...
Letzte Woche über drei verschiedene Animes
geguckt.
Bald ist Weep-Time angesagt.
Normalerweise... Ich hab früher nie Animes geguckt.
Aber witzig ist,
ich guck nix Actionreiches.
Ich guck so ultra
belangloses
Wohlfühlzeug irgendwie.
Ja, ich weiß nicht,
wie das funktioniert mit Systemde.
Ich weiß nicht.
Okay, wir fragen das Archlinux-Wiki.
Das weiß bei sowas eigentlich immer Bescheid.
Alter, ist das laggy?
Was ist denn da los?
Sailor Moon? Nein, nein.
Mit Debian
wäre das nicht passiert. Das ist richtig.
Das stimmt.
Mit Debian hätte ich zwar die Hälfte der Software nicht,
aber korrekt, mit Debian wäre das
nicht passiert.
Okay, Systemdeboot...
Heißt das BootD?
Wie heißt denn das?
Archlinux.
Also. Install.
Moment, Moment.
Bevor ich an meinem Bootloader rumfuddle,
machen wir erstmal einen Snapshot.
Eines der weiteren Riesen-Vorteile von 4Ms.
Boot CTL install.
Das hab ich ja wahrscheinlich schon.
Installation using
Xboot LDR.
Nee, nee. Installate hab ich doch schon.
Updating.
Update?
Okay, das erscheint mir super
Typisch Systemde. Versteht keine Sau,
will er zu sein.
ESP
Loader Conf.
Ist der Loader
das, was im Bootmenü drin steht?
Okay, wählen wir mal
Root.
CD slash Boot.
Und dann Loader.
Loader Conf.
Nee, das ist...
Alter, das ist ultra laggy.
Loader?
Entries?
Was ist das denn?
Type 1. Okay, alles klar.
Obviously. Chat, ich hoffe jedem ist klar,
was Type 1 bedeutet.
Das ist so offensichtlich, das muss ich jetzt
nicht erklären.
Ach, guck mal hier.
Created by Arch
Install am 21.01.
Okay, ich werd mir das mal
kopieren.
Keine Ahnung, was ich hier mache. Ich kopiere das mal.
Und nennen wir es mal
Linux LTS Conf.
So.
Linux.
Ja gut, aber
wie lade ich denn jetzt mein LTS
Zeug? Was habe ich denn im Boot alles drin liegen?
Ach, guck mal.
Minus LTS.
Äh.
LTS.
Ähm.
Arch Linux
LTS. Ups.
Oh.
LTS.
Lits LTS.
Ähm.
Das Wallpaper ist Bock.
Das kannst du auch verwenden, wenn du willst. Das gibt's öffentlich
auf GitHub.
So, jetzt ist die Frage,
wenn ich jetzt reboote,
sind dann die Einträge schon geändert?
Guck mal, wie das laggt.
Das ist ja nicht normal.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Chat, was meint ihr? Steht jetzt LTS
zur Auswahl oder nicht?
Okay. Ich. What?
Das war ein bisschen
schnell.
Also die Bootmenü Auswahl
war vielleicht etwas
zu quick.
Ja.
Da muss ich wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen Tastatur spammen.
Okay. Ich spamme jetzt einfach die Up
und Down-Taste.
In meiner VM. Dann sollte
ich. Ja. Easy.
LTS.
Pog.
Guck mal, wie viel schneller das ist. Seht ihr das?
Und jetzt laggt auch nichts mehr.
Fixed. LTS-Körnel.
Okay. Wir müssen warten, bis es einen neuen Körnel gibt,
dass meine VM nicht mehr ruckelt.
Nice.
Guck mal hier.
Jetzt laggt nichts mehr.
Ich muss den Körnel nicht anzeigen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein LTS-Körnel.
Das ist komplett
ein Unterschied wie Tag und Nacht.
Hier laggt nichts mehr. Alles flüssig.
Was war der Fix
für den Lag? LTS-Körnel
installieren. Der neueste Körnel hat irgendwelche Schmerzen
in meiner VM.
So ist das halt, wenn man
Pleading Edge Arch Linux, by the way, benutzt.
Nee, guck. Keinerlei
Lags.
Okay. Sehr schön.
Und jetzt mal
Updates hinterher.
Sehr gut. 6.1 LTS.
Das wird's gewesen sein.
Das Rust-Feature
hat das Lag verursacht.
Sehr schön. So.
Sehr schön.
Was?
Wie was?
Du hattest das auch in Manjaro. Hast du das auch in der VM?
Was hältst du von Immutable-Betriebssystemen?
Hab ich mir noch nie Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Ich mein,
in Zeiten von Containerisierung
und möglichst
Immutable-Infrastruktur
und eher
Ender neu aufbauen, ist das irgendwie
ein logischer Schritt?
Für tägliche Arbeit
bin ich mir da nicht so sicher, ob das
der Weisheitsletzter Schluss ist.
Was für Animes ich
geguckt habe. Okay, also.
Ich hab zuerst geguckt
die zweite
Staffel von, äh,
wie heißt, ich weiß nicht, wie das auf Japanisch heißt,
äh, Jobless
äh,
fuck, wie heißt das?
Nicht Resurrection?
Jobless Reincarnation
hab ich geguckt, die zweite Staffel.
Wie gesagt, ich werd noch zum Ultra Weep
hier, ich sag's euch.
Dann hab ich geguckt,
ähm,
wie hieß das?
I maxed out my levels
while killing
Slimes for 300
years oder irgendwie sowas.
Frag mich nicht, wer sich diese Titel ausdenkt.
Und dann hab ich geguckt
Kobayashis
Dragon Maid.
Leute, fragt mich nicht.
Das sind alles
übelst so, wie nennt man das?
So
cute Zeug.
Weiß nicht, warum
mir das gerade so zusagt.
Das ist super
entspannend, alles
zu gucken, weil da passiert
nix Schlimmes. Das kannst dir
angucken
und dann denkst du, ja, die Welt ist in Ordnung.
So.
Weiß nicht. Ich sag euch, Leute, ich werd hier noch
zum
Weeps in.
Ja, das hab ich
gehört. Aber eigentlich bin ich gar nicht
so der Riesen-Anime-Gucker.
Aber so die letzten paar
Wochen hab ich tatsächlich recht viel
geguckt in der Richtung.
So.
Nur eins muss ich sagen,
so der japanische Humor, der zündet
nicht so wirklich. Da muss man sich ein bisschen
dran gewöhnen.
Also was mir aufgefallen ist, die Japaner
finden es super lustig,
wenn irgendwas
Blödes passiert und
sich einer dann gefühlt
zwei Stunden lang entschuldigt
und von allen dafür
angeschrien wird. So diese Szenen
gibt es in allen möglichen
wiederkehrenden Varianten.
Das scheint so ne typische
Japan-Humor-Geschichte
zu sein.
Keine Ahnung.
Damit werd ich auch nicht so wirklich warm
mit manchen Sachen, wo ich mir denke, okay, also
super lustig war das jetzt nicht.
Aber dafür ist
die Welt irgendwie,
wenn man sich die richtigen Sachen anguckt, in Ordnung.
Wahrscheinlich ähnlich,
wie wenn meine Mutter im ZDF
Rosamunde Pilcher guckt, guck ich
mir irgendwelche Cute-Animes
an. Dann
ist die Welt in Ordnung.
Was wird
gemacht? Nix.
Ich weiß nicht, was mit
den Titeln los ist, ja. Die Titel
sind teilweise drei Seiten lang.
Äh.
Bestimmt nicht.
Wie gesagt, normal bin ich eigentlich kein großer
Anime-Gucker, zumindest bis jetzt.
Ja, kein großer Anime-Gucker.
Vielleicht,
vielleicht waren die Sachen...
Alter, was ist mit der Musik los?
Ah.
Vielleicht war...
Vielleicht waren die Sachen, die ich bisher
in der Vergangenheit mal immer so ein bisschen
Probe geguckt hab, einfach nicht mein Genre.
Keine Ahnung. Hat mir nie so
sonderlich zugesagt.
Also die letzten paar, die ich geguckt hab,
fand ich ganz nice.
Ich kann halt mit diesem ganzen übertriebenen
5000 verschiedenen
Attacken und...
Wie soll man das beschreiben? So...
So...
Ich wurde verletzt.
Aber...
Ich habe nicht mit voller Kraft gekämpft.
Damit kann ich ehrlich gesagt relativ wenig
anfangen.
Also ich hab bisher nichts auf Deutsch
geguckt. Den einen hab ich
auf Englisch geguckt und die anderen
auf Japanisch mit Untertitel.
Weil das echt anstrengend ist. Da gewöhnt man sich aber
wahrscheinlich mit der Zeit dran, oder?
Untertitel lesen.
Sobald man sagen muss,
die Story ist bei den meisten
nicht so super komplex.
Dass man da
gar nicht mitkommt, wenn man auch nur
so...
Also es reicht eigentlich, wenn man so ein paar Wörter in den Untertitel liest
und dann versteht man schon...
Versteht man eigentlich
meistens, worum es geht.
Igel, danke für den Sub.
So. Oh!
Besos muss
ins Weltall, Leute.
Der Scam-Train ist
am Start.
Was war das für eine Frage hier oben?
Irgendwas hab ich grad gelesen.
Kann man bei Hetzna
einfach eine Windows 10 Anwendung laufen lassen,
auf die ich von überall zugreifen kann,
um es wie ein Desktop
zu verwenden?
Das kannst du?
Also einfach
eine Anwendung kannst du nicht laufen lassen.
Du kannst dir den Windows Server in der Cloud
kaufen und darauf was laufen lassen.
Das kannst du mit
RDP verwenden
wie ein Desktop, aber halt wie ein bisschen
laggy Desktop. RDP ist halt
laggy. Ich mein, okay,
X-Forwarding ist noch deutlich mehr laggy,
aber trotzdem. Also du kannst...
Das ist nicht zu vergleichen mit
irgendeinem
Game-Streaming-Service
von der Latenz oder so.
Es ist auch ehrlich
gesagt nicht dafür gedacht,
Desktop-Anwendungen laufen zu lassen.
Also könntest du machen, ist aber wahrscheinlich keine
zu schlaue Idee, zumal das Ding auch
public im Internet erreichbar sein müsste.
Dementsprechend,
um es sicher zu machen, müsstest du wahrscheinlich
noch ein VPN bauen. Da nicht.
Also wenn du sowas haben willst, ich glaube,
Microsoft selbst hat mittlerweile
Windows-Cloud-Windows-VMs,
die wohl auch mit
Hardware-Acceleration und
verbessertem RDP und so funktionieren,
möglichst latenzfrei. Habe ich aber noch nicht
ausprobiert. Keine Ahnung, wie das so ist.
JustMath, danke für den Sub.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Heute zeigt einfach Mist an.
Ja, das stimmt.
Deswegen finde ich
SSH halt pock.
SSH ist halt schön
per default sicher.
Okay. Datenbank mit
Anwendungen, wie sinnvoll aufbauen?
Drei Anwendungen mit je einer DB?
DBs auf VMs laufen lassen
von außen drauf connecten oder alle DBs
zu einer migraten?
Und dann mit Nutzern von
außen drauf, wo jeder Nutzer nur
seine DB sehen kann.
So hundertprozentig habe ich es noch nicht kapiert.
Dir geht es im Prinzip darum,
ob du
eine fette Datenbankkiste
hinstellen willst, wo dann die Anwendung
jeweils drei, also eine
fette Datenbank
Instanz
VM und da drin
dann für jede Anwendung eine Datenbank anlegen.
Kann man machen.
Also wenn das
alles zu einem Service gehört und man
es einfach haben will, kann man das ohne Probleme auch
so machen.
Ist schwer zu sagen, was da pauschal
besser ist.
Backup mäßig und so nimmt sich das
nix.
Weil du kannst die Datenbanken auch, wenn die
alle in einer liegen,
unterschiedlich
backupen wie du
willst und restoren.
Also ich persönlich würde
wahrscheinlich
schwer zu sagen,
es kommt ein bisschen drauf an.
Also wenn du da jetzt irgendwie keine
super hochverfügbaren Anforderungen
dran hast oder du irgendwie
Performance Probleme kriegst,
weil die alle super krass
Datenbank
verursachen,
würde ich tatsächlich alles mehr oder
weniger auf eine,
also wenn es halt
Sachen, also wenn das jetzt
irgendwie so was kleines ist, Hobby mäßig ist von dir,
dann nimm eine VM
und hau alle drei Anwendungen
drauf inklusive Datenbank fertig.
Dann würde ich mir gar keine Gedanken zu
machen.
Wenn das
was
Business mäßiges ist,
dann würde ich tatsächlich ganz anders machen.
Dann würde ich gar keine Datenbank
selbst betreiben, sondern mir eine
Managed Datenbank irgendwo holen.
Dann muss ich mich
nämlich nicht um die Datenbank großartig
kümmern, was Updates vom OS
und sonst was angeht.
Und Backups sind auch easy
als Fuck zu machen.
Aber natürlich muss ich ein bisschen mehr bezahlen.
Hat aber den Vorteil,
du musst dich halt um nix kümmern.
Es soll alles im Haus bleiben.
Ich glaube, man
kann das pauschal nicht sagen.
Also wenn das was, ich würde
wahrscheinlich dann eher danach gehen,
wie intern
die,
das Management von den Anwendungen
gehandhabt wird. Also sprich,
wie sehr
macht es Probleme,
wenn die Anwendungen von drei unterschiedlichen Teams
betreut werden, mit unterschiedlichen
Releasezyklen und allem,
wenn das alles auf einer
großen Datenbank-VM zusammenläuft.
Ich meine, eigentlich, in der Theorie
sollte das ja nix machen.
Das hängt ja alles nicht zusammen, obwohl es
in der gleichen VM läuft.
Aber vielleicht gibt's ja doch mal
irgendwelche Wartungsarbeiten, wo dann die
zentrale VM runtergefahren werden muss und die
einen sagen, ja, unsere Anwendung
darf nur ab Mitternacht
stehen, die anderen sagen, das darfst du auch
tagsüber machen und die nächsten kommen an. Ja,
ab zwei Uhr nachts ist okay.
Wenn es da so organisatorische Probleme gibt,
dann ist vielleicht besser, man macht drei
einzelne Kisten.
Handhabungstechnisch würde ich sagen, ist
wahrscheinlich das
angenehmste, eine Datenbank zu haben.
Und
je nachdem, wie das Management der Kisten
ist, bietet es sich vielleicht
auch an, die
ganzen Anwendungen
selbst auf eine
VM zu machen.
Eventuell mit ein bisschen HA,
aber je nachdem, was es
ist, braucht er das vielleicht doch gar nicht.
Aber man nutzt es damit nicht,
jeder was sehen kann. Naja, jeder kann ja
gar nichts sehen.
Weil die Leute gehen ja nicht direkt auf die Datenbank,
die gehen ja auf dein
Web-Backend, an deine Web-API.
Gut,
du kannst jetzt natürlich sagen, okay, wenn du
eine Sicherheitslücke in deiner
Backend-Software hast,
dann könnte man theoretisch auf
Daten der anderen Anwendungen darüber zugreifen,
wenn man irgendwelche SQL-Sachen
darüber ausführen kann, ja, dann
musst du gucken, dass du deine Berechtigung in der
Datenbank so vergibst, dass der eine das andere
nicht lesen kann. Das ist aber gar kein Ding.
Also das ist wirklich kein Problem. Also ich weiß es
nur in Postgres, in Postgres ist das ziemlich einfach.
Datenbank-User anzulegen
und Berechtigung zu vergeben.
Übrigens auch schön, wenn du eine Managed-Datenbank hättest,
kannst du das direkt,
wenn du per Terraform aufbaust, oder über das
jeweilige Cloud-Web-Frontend machen.
Oh, was ist mit dem Chat los?
Ah, willkommen im Chat.
Okay.
Warum hat er Nightbot Overwatch
2019?
Moment, was siehst du als Nachteil
von flachen Hierarchien?
Boah.
Jetzt holst dir da aber die Fivehead-Questions am Start,
oder?
Ähm.
Sehe ich da irgendwelche
Nachteile?
Dass alle einem auf den Sack gehen.
Ähm.
Keine Ahnung.
Erfällt mir jetzt so spontan.
Ganz ehrlich, hättest du mich das umgedrehte gefragt.
Was siehst du als Vorteil
von flachen Hierarchien, wenn ich genauso
überlegen müssen?
Ich glaube, man muss sich als erstes mal Gedanken drüber machen,
ab wann ist eine Hierarchie flach?
Was ist denn
für dich eine flache Hierarchie?
So nach dem Motto,
sobald es mehr als zwei Ebenen
gibt, mehr als drei?
Oder wie ist das? Also.
Ich mein.
Dort, wo ich
bisher gearbeitet hab, und dort, wo ich jetzt arbeite,
ist es eigentlich relativ ähnlich.
Da würde ich sagen, es ist nicht übertrieben
mit Hierarchien, aber es gibt halt
recht sinnvoll aufgeteilte
Sachen. Also bei uns ist es so,
wir haben einen Teamleiter,
der ist,
der hat dann vielleicht
verschiedene Unterkrüppchen, die haben aber keine
eigenen Leiter mehr. Also
beispielsweise bei uns, wir haben
ein Team für Linux,
ein Team für Storage, und ein Team für Windows.
Jeweils mit
so, Leute sind
für so sieben Stück oder so.
Also sagen wir mal, so plus, minus,
so in dem Dreh, so um die 20 Leute
pro Team.
Da drüber gibt's dann
einen Abteilungsleiter
IT.
Äh, das stimmt nicht. Da drüber, nein, nein, nein.
Da drüber gibt's dann einen Abteilungsleiter
für IT-Infrastruktur.
Und da drüber gibt's noch
einen IT-Abteilungsleiter.
Fragt mich nicht, wie man das dann nennt.
Also,
das würde ich nicht sagen, dass das flach ist,
aber ich find's eigentlich ganz sinnvoll,
vor allem halt auch bei der Größe.
Also das, ja,
weiß ich nicht, ob das so sinnig ist.
Ich mein,
es hat sicherlich seine Vorteile, dass, also
ich kann jetzt auch nur raten, also sowas,
sowas hatte ich noch nicht,
dass du Teams hast und darüber
kommt das CEO, so nach dem Motto.
Oder du hast Teams, Teamleiter,
CEO. Also das hatte ich in der,
in der, naja, doch, doch.
Damals, als ich beim Internetprovider
gearbeitet hab, war das so, aber das war ja
auch, wie viele hatten wir da?
200, 250 Leute oder so, Mitarbeiter.
Da hatten wir unterschiedliche Teams,
hatten einen Teamleiter und
danach kamen eigentlich schon die Chefs.
Ja.
Was war da der Vorteil von?
Hab ich jetzt eigentlich keinen gesehen,
weil die, weil die mir extrem auf den Sack
gegangen sind. Ich mein, man kriegt
vieles schneller mit. Das mag
vielleicht eines der Vorteile sein.
Beziehungsweise
ungeschönter. Das ist vielleicht auch eines
der Nachteile von so
ein bisschen komplexeren Hierarchien,
dass vieles gefiltert
wird, von unten nach oben
und von oben nach unten, in der
Hierarchieebene, wenn's
die, also wenn's die Ebenen dazwischen verkacken.
Weiß ich
jetzt nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Fällt mir echt
nichts ein, zu gerade.
PDE vs.
IDE.
Wollen die mir sagen, ein Personal
Develop Environment vs. ein Integrated?
Was auch immer. Die Leute
machen da immer eine Wissenschaft draus.
Das reimt sich auf
keinen Stream hin. Ich würde sagen, ein Stream, oder?
Oder was muss man da
generell sagen? Was reimt sich auf Stream?
Mean.
Keine Ahnung.
Scream.
Stream.
Beam. Team.
Beam auch.
Stream.
Meme. Meme reimt sich auch, oder?
Stream und
Meme. Naja, nicht wirklich.
Nicht wirklich gut, oder?
Stream, Meme. Naja.
Naja, sehr.
Sehr halbherzig.
Sonst fällt mir nichts mehr ein.
Fragen wir
doch mal.
Stream, Reimen.
Okay.
Was reimt sich auf Stream?
Alter!
Was
sind das für Vorschläge?
Was reimt sich auf Stream?
Naziregime.
What the fuck?
Was ist das für eine Seite, man?
Alter, das wäre
das Letzte, woran ich gedacht hätte.
Was reimt sich auf
Stream, Alter?
Merkwürdige
Seite, Alter.
Chat, müsst ihr zugeben,
da hättet ihr jetzt auch nicht dran gedacht, dass sich das
drauf reimt.
Reimt sich besser als Meme.
Naja.
Moin, Anpil.
Irgendwelche Subs übersehen?
Hab ich übersehen.
Anpil, dankeschön für den Sub.
Weißt du, woran ich das gesehen hab?
Dass ich wahrscheinlich was übersehen hab.
Weil ich hab deinen Namen hier relativ selten gesehen.
Hab aber gesehen, okay, du hast einen Kekse.
Moment.
Du hast schon öfters mal.
Das ist der zweite Monat schon.
Hab ich gar nicht mitbekommen.
Marv, PogSubscription
hier.
Gut, da kann ich meine
Vr mal wieder ausmachen.
Übrigens, letztens, jemand bei uns
auf der Arbeit
hat gemeint, er fährt Server nur runter
mit Init
Keine Ahnung, was muss man dafür überhaupt machen?
Init 0 oder ist das Reboot? Init 5?
Ich weiß
gar nicht, wie man damit einen Server runterfährt,
ehrlich gesagt.
Und
bis ich dann rausgekriegt hab, dass der
früher reiner Solaris-Admin war
und da macht man das wohl so.
Weiß ich nicht.
Was war?
Init 5 ist Reboot?
Nee, Init 5 ist
Reboot.
Und was ist?
Init Reboot?
Ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Init 6 ist Reboot, okay.
Init 6?
Macht nix, okay.
Init 0? Macht auch nix.
Okay, nice.
Halt?
Wirklich?
Tatsächlich?
Oh, CPU has been disabled.
Okay, alles klar.
Ich hab vor allem den Geist aufgegeben.
Also, ehrlich gesagt,
ich benutze nur Power Off und Reboot
und an was anderes.
Aha, ja, das ergibt natürlich Sinn.
Oh nein!
Ich hab wieder meinen verbackten Kernel geladen.
Wo stellt man denn hier
bei Systemd um, dass der
den richtigen lädt?
Warte mal.
Boot? Loader?
Loader Conf vielleicht?
Okay,
Timeout 3 ist okay.
Tja, wo stellt man hier den Default ein?
Entries?
Tja,
das weiß ich nicht, wie das geht.
Dann reboote ich jetzt nochmal
und starte den LTS Kernel.
Ist das laggy?
Was backt da so rum?
Crap, das ist kein Crap.
Das ist Systemd Boot.
Ich hab mir bisher
noch nie Gedanken drum gemacht,
bei Crap hätte ich's gewusst, wie das funktioniert.
Aber Systemd Boot
D oder wie sich das nennt,
da weiß ich das nicht.
Max, machst du eigentlich
jetzt eher Linux in der Cloud oder ist das Zeug
zu 95%
Linux Cloud?
Aktuell zumindest.
Wir haben aber auch relativ viele Systeme noch
on Prem, wie die coolen Leute das sagen,
stehen. Da mach ich auch ab und zu was,
aber aktuell ist es 95%
Cloud.
Und davon tatsächlich auch
Linux nur so quasi von der
Zuständigkeit her.
Es sind zwar letztendlich Linux-Kisten,
aber es ist hauptsächlich
Linux-Kisten unten drunter, aber es ist hauptsächlich
Kubernetes oder
sehr viel Terraform in letzter Zeit
für Infrastruktur aufzubauen.
Natürlich baut das dann oftmals Linux-Kisten
auf, aber mit denen
hab ich dann gar nicht so viel zu tun.
Ich muss denen auch mal
alle beibringen, wie man richtig diagonal
skaliert. Die skalieren glaube ich
nur horizontal aktuell.
Und die müssen
auch mal lernen, wie das richtig geht.
Wie dreidimensional
diagonal
skaliert wird. So wie
sich das gehört.
Wenn man richtiger 5Head Cloud Native
sein möchte.
Stonks.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Stimmt! Das Video
wurde mir eben empfohlen auf
YouTube. Das gucke ich mir
jetzt mal an. Microsoft sagt nämlich,
dass es jetzt
einen Copilot für Windows 11
gibt. Das ist glaube ich Teil von dem, was
wir uns letztens angeguckt haben, aber
wir gucken uns mal das offizielle Werbevideo
von Microsoft dafür an.
Wahrscheinlich um festzustellen,
dass es wieder irgendein
halbherziger Schrott am Ende ist.
Aber man weiß ja nie so
genau. Lass uns mal die
eine Minute
40 oder wie lang ist es? Eine Minute 51.
Mal kurz checken.
Was ist eigentlich horizontal und diagonal
skalieren? Klar aber horizontal und
diagonal. Also
ich versuche das mal zu erklären.
Horizontal skalieren.
Ich bring das immer ein bisschen durcheinander.
Ich versuche mich mal zu konzentrieren, dass ich es
nicht falschrum wieder erzähle.
Also wenn man von skalieren
bei Infrastruktur spricht, dann gibt es
hauptsächlich zwei verschiedene Sachen, die man machen kann.
Das eine ist horizontal
skalieren und das andere ist vertikal skalieren.
Mit horizontal skalieren ist gemeint,
man startet die Anwendung
auf mehreren, also im Angeln
du hast eine Anwendung, die du betreiben willst,
es gibt mehr User,
nächsten Monat noch mehr User,
noch mehr User, noch mehr User,
oder du hast morgens viele User,
abends keine, also es fluktuiert relativ
stark und
dann hast du jetzt die Auswahl,
ok, was mache ich? Man kann zum Beispiel
sagen, ich skaliere horizontal.
Das bedeutet, du startest die Anwendung
einfach mehrfach.
Also du skalierst das in die
Breite.
Und wenn dir die
Hardware nicht mehr ausreicht mit den CPU-Cores,
dann stellst du eine zweite Hardware daneben,
zum Beispiel im Kubernetes-Cluster,
einen weiteren Cluster-Node
daneben und startest die Anwendung mehrfach.
Also du gehst quasi in die Breite.
Das nennt man horizontal skalieren.
Vertikal skalieren wäre das Gegenteil davon.
Du machst die Kiste,
auf der die Anwendung läuft, fetter.
Du upgradest die.
Du gibst dir 128
Gigram und
noch zwei CPUs
mehr. Das wäre
vertikal skalieren.
Und nachdem das ja
jeder kann
und wir hier im Stream Pfeiffert sind,
skalieren wir einfach diagonal.
Das ist nichts, was es in der
Wirklichkeit gibt. Das ist einfach was,
was ich mir hier ausgedacht habe.
Aber du kannst damit sicherlich
die einen oder anderen Consultants verwirren,
wenn du die das fragst.
Weil Consultants haben ja immer so diese
diese
allwissende
Aura,
die sie sich gerne
andichten wollen, so nach dem Motto
Ich weiß das,
ich weiß das schon.
Und du kannst ja mal einen
Consultant fragen, ob er dann auch
Lösungen
fürs diagonale
Skalieren anbieten kann.
Und da bringt man bestimmt den
einen oder anderen ins Schwimmen, weil er keine Ahnung
mehr hat, was du eigentlich meinst.
Naja, kann man nicht horizontal
und vertikal skalieren oder nicht beides?
Naja, weil du
entweder horizontal skalierst oder
vertikal. Du kannst natürlich
sowohl als auch,
also du kannst auch beides machen, aber da hast du
nicht wirklich diagonal skaliert,
sondern du hast einmal deine Kisten
erweitert und noch Kisten
stärker gemacht. Also, du hast
einmal horizontal skaliert und dann
vertikal skaliert. Es ist nicht so,
dass es wie in Paint wäre,
wo man einfach oder in irgendeiner Bildbearbeitung
so hier diesen Skalierungsdings hoch
nach rechts oben
zieht und auf einmal werden
deine Kisten größer und näher.
Was ja in Paint auch nicht passiert.
Wenn man es genau nimmt,
skaliert Paint eigentlich
nur vertikal.
Also, für Infrastruktur gesprochen
skaliert Paint nur
vertikal. Also nehmen wir mal an,
du hast hier einen Server, du hast hier einen Server,
du hast hier noch einen Server und wenn du jetzt in
Paint sagst, ich hoffe das geht in Paint,
wenn du jetzt in Paint sagst, ich skaliere das
diagonal, dann
hast du in Wirklichkeit eigentlich nur vertikal
skaliert, weil deine Kisten fetter wurden.
Aber es wurden nicht mehr Kisten.
Also aus Infrastruktursicht ist das
eigentlich nur vertikal skaliert.
Ey Max, ich überlege, um meinen Arbeitgeber
zu wechseln, hast du eine Idee,
wie ich nach einem Zwischenzeugnis fragen kann,
oder dass es komisch ist?
Ja, hab ich.
Also wenn du nicht einfach sagen willst, Jungs, ich bin schon so lang
dabei,
wie sieht es mal aus mit dem Zwischenzeugnis?
Es gibt zwei Sachen, die immer ganz gut sind. Das erste
ist
vorgesetzten Wechsel
und das zweite ist, was immer geht,
du sagst dein Aufgabengebiet hat sich die letzten
Jahre über oder die letzten Monate oder was auch immer
erweitert, verändert,
wie auch immer
und nachdem wir in der IT arbeiten und laufen,
irgendwelches neues Zeug dazukommt, ist das eigentlich
immer was geht.
Und dann sagst du,
das ist das und du willst ein Zwischenzeugnis haben.
Letztendlich werden die
immer ein bisschen was wittern,
wenn du nach einem Zwischenzeugnis fragst,
weil niemand fragt random nach einem Zwischenzeugnis,
aber ich persönlich finde das nichts
Schlimmes, nach einem Zwischenzeugnis zu fragen.
Ja, genau so sieht es aus.
Ja.
Es kommt immer auf die Anwendung an, letztendlich.
Ja, genau. Es kommt letztendlich immer auf die
Anwendung an.
Am besten ist, also im
Cloud-Umfeld, ist es
in der Regel am besten, du kannst, also
wenn du horizontal skalieren kannst,
da fährst du in der Regel besser.
Und wahrscheinlich auch
eine ganze Ecke günstiger.
Also wenn du dir ganz viele kleine
VMs hinstellen kannst als Nodes, ist
das meistens besser, als wenn du drei,
vier mega, super
fette dir hinstellst, die kosten
also im Verhältnismäßig
mehr. Kannst du teilweise
800 Euro im Monat für eine VM bei Google ausgeben,
aber die VM-Preise bei Google sind
eh jenseits von all dem, was ich
privat mir leisten würde.
Also da muss ich sagen, das geht bestimmt,
wenn man Glück hat,
wenn man Pech hat, nicht,
aber das
Ding ist halt das,
es kommt natürlich auch immer ein bisschen auf den Arbeitgeber
an, aber das Ding
ist halt das, selbst wenn die
einen nochmal beschwätzen,
dass man noch da bleibt,
so nach dem Motto, ah ok, bevor
du abhaust, dann geben wir dir doch ein bisschen mehr Geld,
die Sachen, die dich
aufgeregt haben,
die sind ja nachdem du mehr Geld bekommen hast,
nicht weg.
Und es ist selten rein
das Gehalt, warum man den Arbeitgeber wechselt.
Ich mein, das ist
sicherlich eines der wichtigsten Faktoren,
ich mein, wir gehen alle arbeiten, weil wir ordentlich
verdienen wollen, nicht weil wir
sagen, ja, ich mach das nur, weil
ich es so super geil finde.
Also natürlich ist das ein großer Punkt,
aber die allermeisten Leute kündigen
sicherlich nicht nur wegen
dem Gehalt und weil sie woanders mehr bekommen,
sondern das hat oftmals
auch noch andere Gründe.
War ja bei mir auch so, beim letzten
Arbeitgeber, war nicht nur das Gehalt,
war auch der Umgang mit Homeoffice,
wo man immer wieder
tolle Ankündigungen gemacht hat und dann wieder Rückzieher
und auch, dass der Laden
nicht aus seinem eigenen Kack, den er
gebaut hat, lernen wollte
und das immer schön geredet hat.
Ein paar Sachen, die mich genervt haben.
Und in der Summe, ja, natürlich kann man woanders
auch mehr verdienen, in der Summe hat's dann
dazu geführt, dass ich woanders hin bin.
Und hätte ich jetzt von denen mehr Geld
bekommen,
wo sie sich ja auch nicht mal
richtig zu durchringen konnten,
weil sie irgendwie ein bisschen pp-iger
gewesen sind,
den sind ja noch 100,
über 100 Leute, ich glaub 102 Leute angeblich
weggerannt dieses Jahr.
Bis sie es dann endlich mal gecheckt haben,
dass sie den Verbliebenen ein bisschen mehr Geld bezahlen müssen.
Aber selbst das hätte ja
wahrscheinlich nichts gebracht,
weil die Dinger, die mich aufgeregt haben,
ja auch noch da waren.
Gerade der Umgang mit Homeoffice, der war ja auch noch da,
der war ja nicht weg, auch wenn sie mir mehr Geld
gegeben hätten. Also, da hätten sie mir schon
extrem viel mehr Geld geben müssen,
dass mich der Umgang,
nämlich dieses, ach wir kommen jetzt einfach mal alle
wieder zu,
komplett ins Büro und solche Dinger,
dass ich da das weiter
gemacht hätte. Da hätten sie schon sagen müssen,
Max, wir bezahlen dir einfach mal das Doppelte.
Aber selbst dann, selbst dann,
es ist ja nicht so, als bin ich groß auf,
ich mein, ich verdien
über einen gewissen
Level, wo ich sag,
ey,
wenn's jetzt doppelt so viel ist, ist nice,
aber es ist jetzt auch nicht, als müsste ich mich krass einschränken,
wenn's das nicht ist. Da ist es mir lieber,
sie haben
eine ordentliche Homeoffice-Regelung noch dabei.
Das hätte mich trotz doppelt so viel
Geld immer noch abgefuckt.
Und dementsprechend sind die, also,
die sind die Probleme ja nicht weg.
Ja. Aber ich finde
den Rechner, da hat das nichts direkt mit den Preisen
zu tun, ich finde den Rechner für
Azure irgendwie angenehmer als den Google Rechner.
Bei Google fehlt dann irgendwie
immer die Hälfte. Bei Azure bin ich meistens
ganz gut mit hingekommen, aber bei Google, der Google Rechner
ist weird champ.
Nee, perfekt ist es nirgendwo.
Aber bei mir,
also bei mir ist das so,
Sachen, die...
Also es gibt,
es gibt zwei Sachen, die mich, also
es gibt zwei Arten von Dingern, die mich nerven,
ja. Es gibt
Sachen auf der Arbeit, die nerven
mich, weil ich sie halt unsinnig
finde, ja. Wie zum Beispiel in manchen
Bereichen übertriebene, bürokratische...
...
im Kreis gelaufe Zeug,
oder...
Was gibt es da sonst noch?
Ah, irgendwelche...
Irgendwelche Leute,
die meinen hier,
wir müssen das jetzt in
Perl programmieren oder was auch immer, ja.
Irgendwelche, es gibt sicherlich ein paar Sachen, die mir auf den Keks gehen,
so technischer Natur und
sowas, aber das interessiert mich persönlich
nicht. Das ist nichts, wo ich sagen würde,
oh, da reg ich mich, da reg ich mich
auch außerhalb der Arbeit drüber auf. Da denke ich mir so,
okay, ist es total bescheuert, was in Perl
heutzutage, aber okay, macht halt, wenn ihr wollt,
ja. Okay, aber
da gibt es die andere, da gibt es die andere,
den anderen Typ von Sachen, wie
zum Beispiel, wenn angekündigt
wird, wir sind so ein super krasser,
geiler, moderner Arbeitgeber
und wir haben eine neue Homeoffice-Regelung.
Unsere neue Homeoffice-Regelung lautet
so nach dem Motto, Mitarbeiter
first und wir sind die allergeilsten
und klärt einfach mit eurem
Chef ab, wie man das
mit Homeoffice bei euch umsetzen kann und
wir kommen euch dann entgegen
und füllt einfach nur mit eurem Chef
zusammen diesen Antrag aus, reicht den ein
und dann ist alles gut und sobald man den
Antrag abgegeben hat, heißt das,
blö, wir lassen einfach nichts mehr von
uns hören und ihr kommt gefälligst wieder ins Büro.
Wir haben uns einfach nicht mehr dran erinnert, was wir
noch vor zwei Monaten erzählt haben.
So, das sind dann so Sachen, die regen mich nicht nur
in der Arbeit auf, die regen mich auch so weiterhin
auf und die gehen
halt auch durch mehr Gehalt nicht weg.
Die ersten
Sachen sind mir eh schon egal
und durch mehr Gehalt werden
die mir noch egaler, wenn's mich nervt,
okay, aber manche
Sachen fucken mich ab und da ist
mir auch egal, wie viel Geld die mir bezahlen.
Die ärgern mich dann weiter.
Und es gibt, deswegen, perfekt
entfernt, dass es nichts gibt, was dich aufregt,
das ist so,
aber es sollte wenig von
diesem Typ 2 aufregend sein, sondern
solange das alles Typ 1 aufregend ist,
ist das okay. Also,
da sind wir gar nicht so weit voneinander
weg. Guck mal, ich hab auch noch nicht oft
meinen Arbeitgeber gewechselt.
Ich hab beim Provider meine Ausbildung gemacht
und
danach kurz da gearbeitet.
Dann bin
ich gewechselt zur Bank in Frankfurt.
Da war ich jetzt
ne ganze Weile und jetzt
bin ich zur Versicherung in Frankfurt gewechselt.
Das war's.
Okay, von
meinen BWL-Ausflügen reden wir jetzt
nicht. Das war's.
Aber,
ich hab ja davor noch eine andere
Ausbildung angefangen.
Aber das lassen wir mal weg. Das zählt nicht
und das hab ich auch nie ernsthaft gemacht.
Also, ich mein, ich hab, wenn du so willst,
eigentlich auch nur zweimal
den Arbeitgeber gewechselt.
Also, für alle, die es nicht wissen,
ich hab mal im Bürokauf angefangen zu lernen.
Und
hab's aber nicht weitergemacht. Oder besser gesagt,
Aufmann für
Büroorganisation.
Richtiger Schrott, Alter.
Das Einzige, was ich von dieser Ausbildung
noch weiß, hab ich auch schon oft gesagt, ist,
wie man eine Buchhalternase macht
und dass man linear oder degressiv
abschreiben kann. Aber
ich hab auch gelesen, dass degressiv abschreiben
nicht mehr geht.
Keck Business.
Ja, dann muss er halt aber auch nicht mit rechnen,
wenn die Leute dann abhauen.
Wie gesagt, es kommt drauf an, ob das
Typ 1-Generve oder Typ 2-Generve
ist. Ich brauche einen neuen
DSL. DSL. O2.
O2 ist doch nur Reseller, oder?
Ja, weil das
ja so gut wie kein Stream heute ist.
Du bekommst nicht mal Überstunden
gutgeschrieben? Dann bin ich mir gar nicht so
sicher, ob das überhaupt legal ist.
Es sei denn, es sei denn, du hast irgendwie
so Vertrauensarbeitszeit, Spezialvertrag
oder sowas, wenn du das nicht hast,
dann sind die sogar, glaub ich, verpflichtet,
aber das ist gefährliches Halbwissen
von mir, eine Zeiterfassung
zu führen. Ja.
Aber nicht nur
daher.
Sebasu-Chan!
Ah, ja, ja.
Danke für den Sub.
By the way, ich use Arch
als Hauptsystem. Endlich kein Window mehr.
Kratz.
Du meinst...
Leute, Achtung, es wird cringe.
Du meinst
Mini-Weich-Window?
Ich find das so cringe,
diese Aussprache, Alter.
Das machen nur die ganzen
heißen Forums-Boomer,
die das so nennen.
Das tut schon richtig weh,
beim Aussprechen.
Das ist das schlimmste
Subreddit, Mann.
Arbeitsleben. Das ist so schrecklich,
was da teilweise für ein Blödsinn geschrieben wird.
Bei denen ist ja
wirklich jeder Ratschlag
so, haha, bist du dumm?
Ich hab besser verhandelt.
Oder
oder
schreibt direkt
Kündigung und Anzeige
ist raus, so nach dem Motto.
Das ist das schlimmste Subreddit.
Ja, danke schön für den Sub.
So, ich wollte mir dieses komische Video...
Steam funktioniert auch.
Ja, es funktioniert mittlerweile erstaunlich viel
unter Linux, was Gaming
angeht. Bis halt
zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo es halt mal nicht funktioniert.
Und dann hast du halt gelitten. Und aktuell
ist eines der größten Baustellen halt
Anti-Cheat. Da wird sich wahrscheinlich
auch auf absehbarer Zeit nichts ändern.
Aber wenn man keine Multiplayer-Games
spielt, oder keine Games
mit totalen, wirren Kopierschützen,
die da Probleme machen,
ist das sicherlich
gut nutzbar, ja.
Macht es Sinn, das Frontend
im Kubernetes-Cluster zu haben? Eigentlich nicht,
weil die... Hä? Natürlich
macht es Sinn, dass Frontend... Moment, Moment,
Moment.
Du meinst nicht
den Server, der dein Frontend ausliefert,
oder? Weil dem macht es Sinn,
im Kubernetes-Cluster zu haben.
Ansonsten verstehe ich die Frage nicht.
Weil, wie du schon
sagst, die eigentliche
Single-Page-Application, oder was auch
immer es ist, da kümmert sich der
Client ja drum, der per
Browser auf dein Service
connectet. Aber
die
Systeme, die das Backend aus, also die
das Frontend ausliefern,
das macht schon Sinn, die im Cluster zu haben.
Bietet sich ja auch an,
die im Cluster zu haben.
Oder du bist so modern
und so bleeding-edge,
dass du sowas per...
Wie nennt sich das?
Edge-Computing, was auch immer machst.
Auf Reddit geht auch keiner
unter 100k arbeiten, ja. Ja, das stimmt.
Ich bin sogar in letzter Zeit
relativ wenig online.
NoLimit, danke schön für den Sub.
Was ist deine Meinung zu SCCM?
Ich weiß nicht, für was
SCCM steht.
Source-Control-Management,
oder was ist das?
Microsoft-System-Center-Configuration...
Oh ne, dazu ist meine Meinung.
Geh mir weg.
Geh mir bloß weg.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen,
Keck Windows, Alter.
Piss dich, Alter!
Damit will ich nix zu tun haben.
Du meinst sowas wie Winget?
Oder
geben wir mal auf Scoop, oder
Schokolad...
Chocolate, oder so.
Ich mein, es liegt
in der Natur der Sache, dass die halt
deutlich beschissener unter Windows sind,
als unter Linux.
Wegen den ganzen Installern und
teilweise auch nur grafischen Sachen.
Aber besser als nix!
Was sagst du
zu PowerShell?
PowerShell ist nice,
für
Automatisierung,
aber nix zum
interaktiv täglich nutzen, find ich.
Sieht Windows Admin sicherlich
anders aus. Sehen Windows Admin
sicherlich anders.
Nein, würd ich auf gar keinen Fall benutzen.
Mal blöd gefragt,
wenn du eine SARS-Anwendung
deployen würdest, AP Frontend
Datenbank, würdest du dieses hosten?
Willst du eine Managed Datenbank?
Wahrscheinlich, oder?
Also willst keine VM und da
eine Postgres drauf machen, du willst eine Managed Datenbank.
Also preis-leistungsmäßig
würd ich halt sagen,
fährst du mit
DigitalOcean wahrscheinlich günstiger als mit
Google und Azure. Die Preise sind
dort teilweise echt pepega.
Aber der Kram funzt
halt einfach. Wobei ich denke
DigitalOcean, hab ich aber persönlich nicht so viel
Erfahrung mit, würd ich sagen, DigitalOcean funzt
halt auch einfach. Also
wenn's nicht so sehr auf Geld
ankommt, find ich Google Cloud nicht schlecht.
Ich sag jetzt mal Google Cloud anstelle
von Azure. Azure kannst du genauso verwenden. AWS
wahrscheinlich auch, mit AWS kenn ich mich nicht gut aus.
Ich sag jetzt einfach mal Google Cloud,
weil ich in letzter Zeit mehr Google Cloud mache
als Azure. Und
je nachdem, was du
vorhast, kannst
du das ja auch richtig Cloud Native
machen.
Also je nachdem, wie
komplex dein
API Endpoint Zeug ist.
Entweder startest du
die Container einfach nur per Cloud Run
und fertig ist.
Du brauchst kein Kubernetes Cluster, keine Linux 4.0
und nix. Oder
du kannst ja auch ein Autopilot Kubernetes Cluster
bauen lassen, je nachdem wie viel
Container Workloads du hast.
Frontend packst du in irgendeinen CDN
und Datenbank
kannst du beispielsweise
eine Managed Cloud SQL Postgres oder sowas
nehmen. Und dann hast du relativ
wenig Sachen, um die du dich kümmern musst.
Kostet natürlich ein bisschen mehr Geld.
Am billigsten ist es auf jeden Fall,
du gehst beispielsweise
zu Hetzner, holst
dir eine Linux 4.0 und machst den Kram selbst.
Dann musst du dich aber auch
um OS Updates kümmern,
um irgendwelche Datenbank
Anpassungen und was
man nicht sonst noch alles für Datenbanken braucht.
Nachdem ich von Datenbanken, das ist tatsächlich eines der
Themen, wo ich sehr wenig Ahnung von habe,
übelster
Noob bin, finde ich ehrlich
gesagt
Datenbanken as a Service
Managed sehr praktisch.
Zumal es da auch mit Backups
und allem total easy ist.
Und Snapshots und sowas kannst du
im Zweifelsfall über das Webinterface machen.
Hast du schon mal was mit Argo CD gemacht?
Ja, habe ich.
Wie man hier im Stream sieht.
Im Archive.
Es ist immer schwierig, da so konkret was zu
zu sagen, weil man die jeweilige Anwendung nicht kennt.
Es gibt ja
da heute tausend Varianten,
was du machen kannst.
Du kannst auch komplett
Fifeld Cloud Native machen, du hast gar
kein Backend, gar keine Backend
AP in dem Sinn mehr, du hast nur irgendwelche Cloud Functions.
Wobei ich sagen muss,
das ist teilweise echt übertrieben.
Das macht auch
einfache Dinge mega komplex.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass es Unsinn ist,
dass es pauschal unsinnig ist.
Aber
was weiß ich, .NET,
Java, Python, Go, was auch immer.
Backend AP
ist eigentlich nichts einzuwenden.
Man kann es mit Cloud Native
und
Skalierung und allem auch
so übertreiben, dass es
kaum mal versteht und
50.000 Euro
im Monat kostet, ohne dass es
irgendjemand benutzt und Geld bringt.
Ich finde, man muss es
nicht übertreiben.
Hast du das überhaupt? Ne, hab ich nicht.
Aber wir haben uns letztens was angeguckt zu Unity.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es da Neuigkeiten gibt.
So, ich wollte mir dieses Windows AI Video
angucken. Okay, also
wir kriegen jetzt den Windows
11 Copilot
introduced, Leute.
Ich hoffe, sie weinen
uns nicht wieder was vor, wie in der Windows 11
Präsentation. Warum sind diese
Werbevideos immer so anstrengend?
Ich krieg
beim Einsetzen der Musik
schon irgendwelche Anfälle.
Alter!
Wer macht denn diese Werbevideos
immer?
Paint! Krass!
It's more secure.
Uiuiui.
Also, das ist sicherlich
cool animiert und alles, aber
ich finde diese Werbevideos
so anstrengend
immer.
Aus den 90er Jahren
die Werbevideos für
Software und Hardware,
die fand ich viel besser.
Die waren immer so unfreiwillig komisch dumm.
Und die hier sind so
Hipster poliert
irgendwie und ich fände die übelst anstrengend
zu gucken.
By the way, so wirklich
AI habe ich jetzt noch gar nicht erkannt.
Ja, New Outlook.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, hier ist AI, Leute.
AI am Start.
Copilot.
Ja, das ist das, was wir uns letztens angeguckt haben.
Choose the conversation
style. Wisst ihr,
was mich
einfach bei vieler Software heutzutage
nervt? Warum muss das
alles aussehen auf dem Desktop,
was die Leute mit Maus und Tastatur
bedienen? Warum muss das alles immer
aussehen wie irgendeine billige Tablet-App?
Ich sag nicht, dass es schlecht
aussieht. Es sieht nach heutigen Maßstäben
gut aus.
So runde Dinger, Schatten,
Kontrast, Animation.
Aber es fühlt sich für mich nicht wie eine
Desktop-Anwendung an, das meiste Zeug.
Das fühlt sich an wie eine billige Tablet-Anwendung.
Open Spotify.
Okay, dafür habe ich AI gebraucht.
Play something
to help me focus.
Essentiell. Ohne
AI wäre ich komplett aufgeschmissen gewesen,
Spotify zu öffnen.
Organize my Windows.
Leute, bis ich Organize
my Windows getippt habe, habe ich mein Windows
in die richtige Ecke gezogen.
Turn on Dark Mode. Witzig, das haben wir auch
als eines der ersten Sachen im Stream
ausprobiert.
Mittlerweile findest du ja in den Windows-Settings nichts mehr.
Das heißt, für sowas ist der AI-Modus
wahrscheinlich gar nicht schlecht.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass das hier
suggeriert, Windows hätte eine coole Animation
beim Umschalten auf Dark Mode.
Also das sieht nicht so aus.
Das ist rein Post-Processing
animiert.
Switchen auf Dark Mode sieht ganz
unspektakulär ruckelig aus unter Windows.
Ja, dass das eingebaut ist,
das finde ich ganz praktisch.
Das ist okay. Das ist gut.
Letztendlich ist AI dafür
auch irgendwo mit am besten geeignet.
Für irgendwelche Texte,
Ideen,
Titel,
Texte zusammenfassen, bisschen umschreiben,
Sätze umschreiben.
Dafür ist AI wirklich gut.
Das ist nice,
dass das eingebaut ist.
Ich frage mich, ob die damit dann auch irgendein
Abo-Modell verkaufen wollen.
So nach dem Motto, sie haben jetzt
20 freie Abfragen
für, keine Ahnung,
in ihrem Office-Paket
sind 20 freie Abfragen, der Rest braucht
ein Chat-GPT-Abo oder
in Windows sind 20 freie Abfragen, der Rest
braucht ein Office-RAN65-Abo.
Sorry, Microsoft-RAN65
heißt es ja, ist ja nicht mehr Office-RAN65.
Boah, man kann den
Kran noch nicht mal richtig
skalieren an der Seite, man kann da nichts
groß...
Alter, diese Hipster-Musik,
die macht mich übelst nervös.
Das ist so schrecklich.
Ah, ich halte diese Werbevideos
nicht aus.
Okay, Background-Remover drin.
Nice, das ist gut.
Braucht man immer mal wieder.
Ja, ich bin zu
Boomer für diese Sorte Werbevideos.
Windows 11.
Nice.
Soll ich euch auch mal
zeigen, was Windows 11 ist?
Was auch super hip und modern ist.
Passt mal auf, ich zeige euch was.
Das hier.
Das ist auch super
hip und modern.
Also vor allem sowas hier.
Das sieht einfach
so modern
und elegant aus.
Diese Icons, die man hat für Ordner
unter Windows.
Ist ja nice, dass man
einen AI-Assistant hat, aber wie wäre es
dann mal beispielsweise mit ein paar gescheiten
Icons? So Abwechslung.
Damit könnte man ja vielleicht irgendwas anfangen.
Oh, High-Res-Bild hier.
Ist der nicht auch
super modern?
Ist das jetzt im Dark-Mode?
Das hier?
Mein Windows ist so halbe-halbe.
Das ist im Dark-Mode, ja, aber nicht alles.
Also das ist im Dark-Mode.
Achso, ja, Moment.
Das ist ja also
das ist jetzt nicht, ich habe jetzt gesagt
mein Windows
das ist nicht nur in
meinem Windows so, das ist normal,
dass unter Windows nicht alles
im Dark-Mode ist, weil das hier kann
beispielsweise gar kein Dark-Mode. Also mein Windows
ist im Dark-Mode, aber
die Ordner-Details, die können kein
Dark-Mode.
Und natürlich das Icon-Auswahl-Menü
auch nicht. Logisch.
Das kann man von Microsoft ja auch nicht erwarten, dass man
so ein Fenster dunkel färben kann.
Die Technologie ist einfach noch nicht da.
Vielleicht sollte man
das mal den
AI-Copilot fragen.
Das Hintergrundbild hast du auch
auf deinem Windows. Weißt du, was noch viel nicer ist
als dieses Hintergrundbild? Das Hintergrundbild.
Und da gibt es ein Hintergrund
für jede Tageszeit.
Guck mal, du hast hier
für jede
Tageszeit hast du.
Du hast Mittagessen, Pepo, du hast
Keks-Ess, Pepo, du hast
Arbeits-Pepo, du hast Energy-Booster
Pepo.
Nudeln und Lachs, Pepo.
Das versteht wahrscheinlich auch keiner, der den Stream
nicht regelmäßig guckt.
Bügeleisen, Pepo.
Workout-Pepo, normaler.
Sonnenaufgang, Frühstücks, Pepo.
Cornflakes, Pepo.
Croissant, schlafen, träumen.
Abends, Dings, YouTube gucken.
Also für jede
Jahreszeit auch. Für jede
Tageszeit ein.
Chat, was haltet
ihr von Windows 11 Copilot?
Jetzt, wo ihr es gesehen habt.
Ich sehe mich das schon benutzen.
Vielleicht für
irgendwelche Text-Zusammenfassungen oder
generiere mir fünf
Clickbait-Titel für YouTube.
Aber ansonsten für die ganzen
anderen Funktionen werde ich sie nicht benutzen.
Für was der Bügeleisen, Pepo, steht?
Für gar nichts.
Für Hausarbeit. Für Bügeleisen.
I quit Amazon
after two months.
Already ripped them.
And I would get like a knot
in my stomach.
...
140.000. Was hat er gesagt?
140.000. Das ist aber für Ami-Verhältnisse, glaube ich, auch gar nicht so krass.
Und dann hat er festgestellt, dass es sackt, bei Amazon zu arbeiten. Das stelle ich mir direkt nach dem Studium schon ziemlich nach Schock vor.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr träumt die ganze Zeit davon, so nach dem Motto, in dem Bereich zu arbeiten und dann vielleicht sogar bei einem der richtig großen Unternehmen.
Und dann fangt ihr da an und dann ist halt das ein richtiger Kackladen.
I joined the Alexa-Org. There were four experienced engineers on the team and like five or six new grads had just joined, including me.
Und one of the first things my manager said to me was, the team is a little burnt out, so try not to ask questions.
Now, usually I don't mind a challenge, but for some reason this was different. I had so much anxiety just trying to read my screen.
I could not concentrate. I felt like something in my brain broke, like the glue that was holding everything together was just coming apart.
Even tasks that were like trivial for me in the past.
Ich meine, wenn du neu in einem Team bist und das Erste, was du gesagt kriegst, ey, hier läuft Scheiße, halt mal die Klappe und frag nix.
Das ist schon blöd, weil wie willst du, wenn du neu irgendwo bist, ohne zu fragen, überhaupt reinkommen? Das geht doch gar nicht.
Das war einfach unmöglich. Meine ganze Lebe hatte ich noch nie so eine Erfahrung, das schwöre ich dir. Ich fühlte mich wie auf Feuer, und ich würde alles tun, um es zu stoppen.
Und so habe ich aufgehört. Mein Gedanke war, ich bin sicher, dass sie mich irgendwie aufheben werden, aber ich bin reasonabel schlau und reasonabel hart arbeitend.
Ich weiß nicht, wie lange es dauert, aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass ich einen anderen hohen bezahlbaren Job einen Tag bekommen werde.
Und selbst wenn es halb so viel zahlt, wie Amazon, für mich ist das immer noch viel Geld.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, vielleicht wollte ich mich einfach nur überzeugen.
Und das lustige ist, als ich eigentlich zuerst mein Resignations-E-Mail geschickt habe, hat mein Manager mich angerufen und gesagt, komm schon, du musst nicht aufhören.
Warum aufhören? Ja, gut, da hätte ich als Manager auch blöd geguckt, so nach dem Motto, wie, du hörst auf, du hast doch erst letzte Woche angefangen.
Aber ich war so, nein, ich bin ernsthaft, das ist scheiße.
Und am nächsten Tag rief mein Senior-Manager mich an und sagte grundsätzlich das selbe.
Irgendwie haben sie mich tatsächlich überzeugt und ich war so, okay, vielleicht kann ich hier Dinge machen.
Und ein paar Tage sind vergangen und für das dritte und letzte Mal habe ich mein Resignations-E-Mail geschickt.
Nach dem Aufhören dachte ich, dass Dinge besser werden. Sie haben es nicht.
Jedes Mal, als ich auf meinem Computer saß und VS Code öffnete, hatte ich so ein intensives Gefühl in meinem Körper.
Und nach einer Weile habe ich einfach aufgehört.
Warum? Also so ganz folgen konnte ich ihm jetzt nicht?
Also was war jetzt das Problem? Also, er ist in ein neues Team gekommen.
Die haben ihm gesagt, wir sind hier ziemlich am Arsch.
Nervt uns nicht.
Okay, ich meine, ich gehe mal davon aus, ich glaube gar nicht, dass es ein wirkliches Skill-Issue ist, bei ihm gewesen ist.
Sondern es war eher, der ist mit dem Umfeld halt nicht klar gekommen.
Das kann ich persönlich auch nachvollziehen.
Also mir fällt es auch schwer, in einem Umfeld zu arbeiten, wo ich halt den Eindruck habe, dass die Leute in einer komplett anderen Welt sind.
Ich glaube, ich habe ein paar Leak-Code-Videos gedreht.
Aber ich habe das sogar aufgehört, weil ich so deprimiert war.
Ich drehte mich um Drogen und Alkohol.
Ich habe den Bong so...
Das eskalierte schnell.
...so viel, dass ich es nicht mehr fühlte.
Ich war einfach in Schock.
Wie ist das passiert für mich?
Das sollte nicht passieren.
Es sollte anders sein.
Wenn ich stärker wäre, würde mir das nie passieren.
Wenn ich nur noch eine Chance hätte.
Ich weiß, dass ich Dinge richtig machen könnte.
Vielleicht in einem anderen Leben, werde ich sie stolz machen.
Das Deppen, mit dem du in einem Umfeld überhaupt nicht klarkommst, ist schwer nachzuvollziehen.
So ähnlich interpretiere ich das auch.
Der hat da angefangen, die haben ihm gesagt, nerv nicht.
Und er saß dann halt rum.
War komplett überfordert mit dem, was man ihm vorgesetzt hat.
Was ja auch schwierig ist, von 0 auf 100 ins kalte Wasser.
Und was ich auch so ein bisschen raushöre, ist, dass er mit dem Umfeld überhaupt nicht klargekommen ist.
Und das kann ich nachvollziehen, dass man da echt Bauchschmerzen hat.
Also wenn du den ganzen Tag auf der Arbeit sitzt.
Und permanent das Gefühl hast, oder den Eindruck hast, dass du hier nicht hingehörst von den Leuten.
Das ist unglaublich schwer zu beschreiben.
Stellt euch vor, ein Freund von euch in der Schule hat Geburtstag.
Und der lädt euch ein.
Aber ein Freund, der nicht bei euch an die Schule geht, den ihr über zwei Ecken kennt, lädt euch zum Geburtstag ein.
Und beim Geburtstag sitzen halt nur Leute rum, die ihr nicht kennt.
Dann könnt ihr auch sagen, ja geil, jetzt kann ich mich einfach mal drei Stunden kostenlos vollfressen.
Aber ihr fühlt euch eigentlich permanent unwohl, weil dort nur Leute sind, die ihr nicht kennt.
Vielleicht komische Leute, wo ihr denkt, alter, mit denen werde ich nie warm.
Irgendwelche nervigen Leute.
Und wenn das halt so ist, muss ja nicht so sein.
Aber es kann auch sein, dass die alle ganz nice sind.
Aber es gibt halt solche Veranstaltungen, auf denen man ist.
Und wenn sich das so auf der Arbeit jeden Tag anfühlt, dann verstehe ich, dass das Umfeld so unangenehm ist, dass du das nicht aushältst auf Dauer.
I grabbed a piece of tin foil.
I opened it and ate everything inside.
It was like five or six tabs of LSD.
Now it was...
Okay, okay.
Okay, das eskalierte jetzt wirklich quickly langsam.
The fuck?
Erstmal Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof.
A horrible decision, but I just wanted to feel like I was flying.
Now I did not fly.
I spent that day laying down and watching the ceiling just spinning.
All of the negative feelings I had were like ten times more intense.
And the thoughts just kept replaying in my mind.
But that wasn't even the worst part of it.
After it was over, the world around me had very noticeably changed.
A school construction project next to where I lived was not really about the school.
It was actually meant to spy on me.
Why? That's the question I kept asking myself.
Okay, da muss man jetzt aber mal fairness halber sagen, da kann jetzt Amazon ja nichts dafür.
Amazon mag gerade in diesem Team vielleicht nicht der passende Arbeitgeber für ihn gewesen sein.
Aber da kann jetzt Amazon wirklich nichts für.
Warum hat er überhaupt ein fettes Paket LSD in seinem Gefrierschrank?
Ja, das ist die richtige Frage.
Why are people following me?
Why is it that every time I drive, police are following me?
I know that sounds crazy, but here's one that's like
Das Soundet ein bisschen nach Kekalu.
a bit believable, at least for like a paranoid person.
In college, I had my only internship at Capital One.
During that time, there was a data breach on their services that were hosted on AWS.
And it was actually intentionally caused by like a former Amazon engineer.
And while I was at Amazon, I would sometimes take like handwritten notes like about my tasks.
So then I started thinking, oh shit, there's going to be another breach.
And Amazon is going to try to blame it on me.
Why? I don't know.
But I took those notes and I burned the shit out of them.
Now, I'm not a big crier.
I'm honestly not.
But in this situation, it was so hard to get better because I just could not stop crying.
Even worse, I couldn't remember anything.
I would get up and walk to the kitchen and be like, wait, what am I doing again?
Wait, how old am I again?
What's my name again?
A doctor's appointment today, I was so scared that I was just completely losing my mind.
But I did not stay down.
Almost every day I would drive to an empty parking lot.
And after I was done crying, I would read to myself.
And I'll actually show you.
Maybe working this particular job caused a little too much anxiety right now.
But as I continue, I know pretty soon it will be easier and more manageable.
You can even see the date.
Last edited August 20, 2020.
I would read these words every single day until one day I could believe them.
Even then, months went by of me doing nothing.
I couldn't eat.
I couldn't sleep.
Or even remember things.
I didn't really know what else to do anymore.
So I think on December 1, 2020, I decided.
Okay, I'm just going to solve a leak code problem every single day.
Regardless of what else happens around me.
And the consistency and predictability of this actually helped me calm down a lot.
And literally a week after that, I started feeling like a tiny bit normal again.
So then I started making leak code videos again.
Literally like a week after that, it was such a strange feeling.
I had to make a video again, by the way.
I think there was a little bit too much in there.
I couldn't do in the past.
I literally feel like somebody else is doing it for me.
Now, I'm not saying that leak code will cure your mental illness.
And I'm not a doctor.
But if I had to guess this whole experience of going crazy was probably like drug induced psychosis.
At least from what I know.
Now, I can't tell you exactly how to get into Google.
I can't tell you exactly how to make a lot of money or whatever it is that you want to do.
I wish I could.
But I can tell you this.
When you're consistent, never stay down.
Enjoy what you do.
Maybe even obsess over it.
And lastly, are honest with yourself and a little self-critical.
You tell me, would you want to bet against someone like that?
I wouldn't.
And for that reason, I'm never going to bet against myself.
I'm Navi.
And that's my story in my own words.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well, I don't know what to say now.
But it's good that I'm feeling better again.
And that I'm hard at leak coding again.
Dustin.
POG Subscription.
He's doing 24 hours leak coding go.
I'm doing 24 hours leak coding kobol soon.
Let's see who's more of a leak.
Yeah.